tout le monde est là mais il va falloir
rentrer mes chéris parce qu'on rentre
pas comme ça regardez donc ces
partenaires gagnaient pas aisée qui sia
a dit t'as quel âge ils ont mis tout un
tas fin de six ans je pensais pas vrai
sarrio en direct en 4ème de big fait
franchement allez vas-y vas-y c'est mon
cas c'est beau les deux vous êtes
ensemble quoi atteint dès qu'elle est
battu change et avec elle maintenant
c'est bon allez vas-y vous ça vous
semble mais c'est qu'il a une famille
c'est qu'ils toute la famille là vous
êtes tous ensemble c'est bon ça passe à
droite ça paye ça ça paye comme le
mariage quatre captures ne pas [ __ ] en
mariage tu rentres de mariage thurrott
un mariage sur quatre nages tôt j'avais
divorcé alors voila tu as dû voir ces
petites remarques 65e mariage il faudra
entrer ok très bien les deux magnifiques
j'aime beaucoup par contre eux c'est bon
merci ah non j'ai pas de notre temps
alors qu'est ce qui se passe quand on
est en bas mais on en 2018
non pas trop dans quoi que tu vois tu en
as quand même si on peut la faire didier
jamet geste non mais c'est pas ça que
votre connais ta seringues ou pas non
tant qu'ils auront ce soir hugo boss
c'est toi quel beau passing partie assez
bon ainsi les kurdes les dossiers avec
des chiffres et des lettres
là c'est pour le mondial de la collision
tu vas première anomalie c'est parti
aulas quel regard qu'on côtoie justement
balle ronde tu rentres pas un petit est
un petit est un petit test pour les
bourses pour kentucky rand pas d'accord
nous l'eau l'eau des nouilles couleurs
des coûts des seuls à bout il met coude
à toi mais nous y coule le long de mes
couilles et ça me mouiller les couilles
je ne peux pas faire c'est mon gérer ce
qu'il a c'est bon ça ça en direct ça ça
en direct par contre faites gaffe aux
tee-shirts les mecs franchement ça oui
ça arrange abdallahi emballé groupe
attendait pour livrer 2,6 eur mais je
suis pas s'en lasser une bouteille
maladies diarrhéiques qui appelez moi je
vais arriver à derniers mois ont tapé
show avec le petit pour surveiller un
peu notamment banon mais je vais
surveiller un peu les petits jeunes gaza
s est révélée on dirait un mélange la
droite de l'algérino et de l'as palette
audi les risques naturels auxquels vous
êtes venus de toutes les deux comme vous
êtes venir toutes les 3 à 3 vous êtes
connus ou allez c'est bon ça rentre au
maire robert gates à tan tan tan talbots
a le mot de passe pour entrer à l'ena
bibliothèque la bibliothèque c'est la
fin allez allez les chairs émission de
foot ce soir de remercier maxime maxime
poivre et sel on est très content que tu
sois des coûts merci le voilà il au
théâtre du gymnase depuis le 26
septembre
on aime beaucoup c'est un pote de très
longue date et je laime fort et il est
excellent et il faut aller voir en
spectacle ou maxime stein c'est la loi
merci au jury d'abord été une bonne
machine à tapas de basket turban